um so Connor has like everyone thinks
it's a meme but Conor
you're like trap like your previous
aparri trash taste shirt every for every
show aside from one right yeah
how the [ __ ] do you do that how the [ __ ]
do you get away with that how many
shirts did you pack for uh I had three
of them so I would just cycle through
them
um and just wash them because you know
every single show had uh well most of
them had laundry yeah so I just did my
laundry even if I had like two two items
I would just throw it in there wasn't
wasteful of energy yeah probably but I
kept it the meme and that's honestly
worth it every time I looked over it you
it felt like groundhog okay yeah
I'm like wait so it's still day one of
the tour or I didn't do every show
because I thought no I'm not gonna do
that and then the second sure I didn't
wear it and then after I was like ah
[ __ ] really I didn't notice it you know
what you know what I found funny is that
you know we had like the our tour staff
members with us and everyone everything
like that and they didn't realize you
had packed multiple shirts until like
two weeks in and I remember someone on
the staff members just awkwardly asking
when was the last time you watched that
shirt
they thought I was wearing the same
shirt the entire tour I was like
um well that would be gross and no I had
three and I just washed them a lot
because they're very good quality and
they could withstand water
yeah but yeah my God man I just it just
makes me want to just take you out on a
day to Tokyo to just like dress you up
but you're not gonna take me out and put
me down
get rid of him just get rid of him dude
I like that I need more clothes that are
good I just it's tough can you let me
coordinate you yeah sure I actually like
this sounds like a joey Channel video
Yeah
someone who owns a clothing brand I want
to take you out and give you some nice
clothes okay I feel like you need it
yeah here's a question how many times do
you guys buy new clothes and when do you
guys make the decision to like bin like
when did you make the decision to bend
old clothes because I'm not one to hold
on to old clothes right I pretty much
get rid of them in the moment I feel
like I'm realistically not wearing this
anymore it just goes in the trash yeah
for my my rule of thumb is if I don't
wear it for at least a month or so yeah
then that probably means I'm not gonna
wear it for the rest of them how
wasteful of us yeah
um but I donate all my clothes so ah
okay I'm the complete
[Music]
[Music]
I am that guy who you open up the
wardrobe right so I remember at my old
at my old place my wardrobe was
completely full right and so I moved
into this new place like last year and
it's great because I have a wardrobe but
I also have like a second storage room
yeah that also has like a clothing rail
I'm like great I finally have more space
for more clothes and
it's like I'm like a year into living in
this new place I'm like [ __ ] both
wardrobes before now bro I I don't even
I try and have my t-shirts and don't
even take up half like a small one
actually I have I have a [ __ ]
confession to make okay so you see I've
you seen me wear this belt right quite a
lot of times yeah it's a nice spell
right yeah I've owned this since I was
17 years old I am I I am not joking this
this is a 15 year old Bell and it's
still it's still like it still holds up
which is why I've never thrown it away
you know what's [ __ ] up I also have a
belt I've had since I was 70. serious
I think this is because you guys have no
no discernible ass cheeks that are large
because bro my belts last a year tops
before they're [ __ ] really it's bro
it's like my belts are like Atlas bro
they're holding it up and then like it
just can only last a year I swear to God
I don't know if I'm buying [ __ ] belts I
I was I thought this was the problem
I'll buy some nice belts yeah so I
started going up in the in the belt
Echelon yeah and I started getting nice
about it so I I got a belt that was like
what I thought was expensive it was like
a hundred dollar bill and I was like
that's [ __ ] expensive for a [ __ ]
but I guess if you're looking for it to
last long time yeah yeah dude this [ __ ]
lasted like six answer is [ __ ] what
are you doing to it I I I'm not I don't
think I'm doing it particularly tight
just tighter than how it would look my
pants up without a belt right so I don't
know what's going on when my belt game
is off maybe I'm doing something wrong
maybe you're just too [ __ ] dummy I
think my ass cheeks are just too big I
think this is the circumference is too
much to handle Connor's Bell uh Connor's
ass the destroyer of what else it's the
shearing Force right because it's an
angled Force it's out you know it's it's
not meant to handle it I also you say
you donate your clothes bro like bro if
I try to donate my clothes it'd be like
what if what the [ __ ] are all these
sweat patches bro they'd be like take
this back
the guy I do the because in Japan right
they have they have a lot of they have a
thing called uh well they recycle the
plastic yeah yes now when you think
about that you're like oh they must be
reusing this plastic no no recycling the
plastic also
contains burning yes yes that also means
recycling yeah so maybe that's how my
clothes are being recycled this is
thrown into a fire oh the amount of odor
into them you put a flame to those
genuinely I I wear my most of my shirts
to the point where like I don't like I
I'm pretty sure I couldn't even donate
half of them they're so [ __ ] 100 my
boxes bro the moment I I'm that kind of
guy who's like whole I'm like one hole
copium it's still good enough it's still
good enough I'm holding your boxes no
that's a tiny hole tiny hole tiny hole
and then I'm like it's still good she's
fine she's sturdy and then literally
like two weeks later it's like [ __ ]
and you're like my lip my literally my
entire dick is out yeah my limit is like
can I pass my fist though I should
probably throw it out
oh no I've had some I mean we talked
about in the past podcast episode but
like I've had boxes that have like holes
like this big and I'm just like yeah
it's still good I do take I I actually
find joy in throwing out clothes or
getting rid of clothes okay I feel like
it's a new level in my life I just find
I just like I should I I should throw
away clothes but I look at some clothes
I'm like maybe I could still make this
work and I just I finally get you bro so
it's I have like a tearless system right
of just like current clothes I'm wearing
yeah clothes that I maybe wanna you know
maybe want to try again and then clothes
that I've like worn once and I'm like
trying to look for like a nice occasion
to wear this clothes and that's like it
just keeps [ __ ] building up and I'm
like what is I don't know what the
normal like level of when you decide to
throw away your clothes because I'm
gonna be honest for most for most of my
life the person who threw away my
clothes was my mum
yeah that was because she was like God
you've not worn these clothes for three
[ __ ] years I'm throwing it out for
you and the thing is she would have to
do it when I was away from home because
she knew if she asked I would like fight
her on it
do you hoard other stuff or is it just
no just clothes just because
I think I don't have like do do you guys
buy new clothes regularly as well
because I I like okay here's the
weirdest half my wardrobe is like yeah
who's just giving me stuff he's the
witness I remember when I was in England
and I was applying for a credit card or
something like that and they had to like
give you they you had to give them like
uh like a breakdown of your expenses
like every month right and so you have
to tell them you know how much you spend
on like uh approximation on how much you
spend on food travel Etc and one of the
categories was clothes now and I
remember thinking when I was applying
for this credit card uh when I was like
18 or something it's like why is clothes
a monthly expense is is it normal to buy
clothes like a new piece of clothing
every month because for me it's
definitely not so I was like what is
what is the normal schedule for buying
new clothes for other people because for
me it's just other people who buy a lot
of clothes yeah yeah like some some
people just you know buy a new thing of
clothes every week if they want to and
they're just like yeah I'll probably
eventually anywhere one of these days
and then they become hoarders like you
so I remember when I was a kid
um you know like uh was it The Learning
Channel TLC yeah
but like obviously this is that type of
reality TV show has been around for a
while yeah and the UK had this kind of
stuff years ago as well wait do you mean
PBS uh no no The Learning Channel which
is the not very much not about learning
it's literally about like the My Strange
Addiction
That's The Learning Channel That's The
Learning Channel yeah TLC that's what it
stands for The Learning Channel I
can we fact check this I'm pretty sure
it's The Learning Channel
um are you serious yeah so that's how is
this addiction learning yeah
there's a lot as on The Learning Channel
good [ __ ]
that'll learn about that perhaps you
shouldn't uh wife someone after 90 days
that's a that's a lesson it's an
education and what not to do with your
life I gotta make sure I'm right I'm
sure that's what it is oh it's both oh
oh it's tenderloin care and The Learning
Channel okay
so the point being is that I just
certainly remember when I was like 15 I
had this very vague memory of one of
these types of shows being on where it
was like My Strange Addiction kind of
vibe but like I don't know if it's real
my clothes for sure this is one guy he
was like like the most British Northern
man ever he's like man I just I just
have to I have to throw away my boxes
after I've worn them I just can't wear
re-wear a pair of boxes I just want only
one-time news yeah
so they would just film shots of him
going into his car and just opening up
new pairs of boxes oh yeah it's good to
have a a fresh batch can't wait to work
it's just like what is this what the
[ __ ] is this he's the reason why there's
a oh there's a hole in the ozone layer
on this channel he was like yeah it's
it's ruining my life and my financials
are terrible yeah I can't afford
anything because I'm spending and he of
course of course he didn't buy like the
family pack Costco yeah it was like I
need Calvin Klein every single day did
he also have a thousand thread count as
well so he was buying he was spending
like 20 quid on a pair of boxes every
single day and he had a jet like just a
normal ass like salary there was nothing
crazy and he was just like I just it's
just too dirty it's sort of re-wearing a
pair of boxes it's disgusting but he's
wearing the same t-shirt pants socks
yeah yeah are you wearing them is he
doing it with socks as well yeah yeah he
was re-wearing everything except for
boxes he just felt like it was dirty I
feel like that's that's some weird
trauma that's literally the meme of
please can you help me uh manage my
expenses food 200 rent 800 boxes 3 200
boxes all these TV shows are like this
they'll be like they'll be like man this
family is having financial difficulties
we brought in a financial expert to sort
it out and I'll be like all right so
yeah rent all right uh yeah wow water
all right food all right so we have 900
on a hot tub annual subscription all
right sorry it's like the financial
expert has figured out what is going
wrong it's like hey hold on it's not
gonna lie yeah we did not need a
financial expert yeah I would have done
this it's just like half the price just
like buy less boxes no
I've tried that every every every single
UK Financial thing it was like 90 of the
time it was like stop ordering take out
food it was literally it was literally
and there was like Wow problem solved
wow thanks Dr K we we have all our money
fixed wow we're wealthy now and it's
like
what is this I'm just I'm just convinced
that like the majority of these like you
know TLC based like families and stuff
like that that you see on Like My
Strange Addiction or whatever they're
not real families no I'm pretty sure I'm
just like they they have to be scripted